I won some time ago that I thought
interest rates were too low I think many
people with hindsight would say that
that was right and that the bank of
England were rather slow in putting up
interest rates they overreacted to
covert cut interest rates too much uh
had quantitative easing that is the
injection of money into the economy and
far too larger scale for too long and
all that has meant that we've got this
degree of domestically generated
inflation which we have to hold this is
in the interest of everybody it's taking
a longer term view of course it's very
awkward politically for the government
but I think Jeremy Hunt should be
uploaded not criticized applauded for
taking a view that is in the National
interest in the wrong letter